hey guys today it is the second of July
my name is jeff mcdonald and you're
watching games but news for those of us
with android devices pouting angrily and
pretending we didn't even want to play
fallout shelter when it was announced
for iOS at e3 a small ray of light has
now shown through today Bethesda VP and
marketing executive Pete Hines revealed
a rough release window for the game's
release on Android in response to a
question about it on Twitter he answered
coming along nice haven't announced
today's but should be out next month
we'll let you know when we have
specifics the free-to-play vault
management game shot to the top of the
iOS game charts shortly after its
release and apparently generated
bethesda a crapload of revenue through
its micro transactions the closed alpha
star wars battlefront is out now and
along with it has been released a whole
bunch of new details so if you didn't
get into it here's what you need to know
a new gameplay video has hit the
internet and fans of dug through the
files contained within the alpha
download to find out exactly what you'll
be getting your hands on in game weapons
appear to include Boba Fett's rifle the
ee three the DL 44 a blaster pistol
famously wielded by Han Solo and a
number of other weapons specific to the
rebel and stormtrooper forces if you
want the lowdown on all the sweet
vehicles you'll be able to hop into they
include the x-wing TIE fighter lambda
shuttle y-wing Corellian Corvette
Nebulon d frigate imperial star
destroyer Mon Calamari capital ship home
180 ft and 80 80 s of course there's
also a range of remotes so you can
really get your point across in any
possible scenario Nintendo will begin
manufacturing then you console the NX
before the year is out according to a
new report Taiwanese publication
DigiTimes has claimed that manufacturing
for Nintendo's annex console is going to
begin by October quote at the latest
claiming Nintendo has signed a contract
with manufacturing giant box conn elec
tronox who are also known for
manufacturing the iphone among other
apple devices Nintendo is currently
expected to reveal the NX around III
2016 although the DigiTimes report
indicates that quote mass production
will start in may or june 2016 while the
consoles official launch may take place
around july the report also indicates
that nintendo want to ship 20 million
and x systems in the first year and the
manufacturing of the wii u systems will
steadily decline nintendo is yet to
comment on the speculation let me know
down in the comments what you want
Nintendo's NX console to be and how you
think the company can improve things
this time around you can head to
gamespot we've got stories on a new RPG
called LX and the two versions of Fire
Emblem fates that will be shipping
through the West that was everything
I've got for you today be sure to pop
back same time tomorrow for my top 5
stories of the whole gaming week i'll
catch you them